c'était fermé aujourd'hui
il savait pas
vous savez quoi le premier mandat d'
emmanuel macron court jusqu'au 13 mai à
minuit au 14 mai à zéro heure selon la
manière dont on présente les choses et
ce que j'ai indiqué c'est que ce que je
sais le gouvernement castex restera en
place jusqu'à la fin du premier mandat
d' emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui
c'est fait aujourd'hui des millions de
gens dans ce pays peuvent espérer voir
leur vie changer dans dans quelques
semaines combien de candidats
socialistes
j'ai pas le chiffre à vous donner en
détail 70 sur les options en tout cas ce
qui est clair c'est que c'est on a fait
ce qu'il fallait parce que c'est plus
que ce que la proportionnelle stricte
qui était quand même le point de départ
est à dire on disait voilà on part de la
proportionnelle à l'élection
présidentielle franchement on a fait
plus que ça nous sommes à quelques
heures d'un moment historique d'un
historique attendu depuis des années par
le peuple de gauche nous ne gagnerons
pas si demain il ya un parti unique
chapeauté par jean luc mélenchon et et
derrière lequel tout le monde devrait se
rallier ça ne marchera pas aujourd'hui
le leader de cette union scellée
français les socialistes ont obtenu 70
circonscription en cas de candidature
unis mais rien n'est encore acquis vous
ferez campagne avec le tract mélenchon
premier ministre ce sera la fiche de
campagne ce sera élisez moi premier
ministre avec la tête de jean luc
mélenchon ce sera ça que vous
distribuerez long si ce parti socialiste
continue à être comme il est aujourd'hui
avec olivier forcé vous êtes d'accord
avec moi sinon vous partez vous si c'est
ça ce parti qui se réduit qui se
recroqueville eh bien je partirai bien
sûr mais je vais pas non plus dire j'ai
à part tout de suite peut pas tolérer
qu'on passe un accord qu'on s'accorde
sur une répartition et puis qu'à côté il
ya des dissidences donc ça veut dire que
chaque formation politique sera engagée
exclure d'accord évidemment essentielle
ment les jeunes et d'ici là sur l'ancien
premier ministre bernard cazeneuve a lui
annoncé ce soir qu'il quittait le parti
socialiste le voilà tout sourire jean
luc mélenchon le troisième homme de la
présidentielle s'est imposée en quelques
jours patron de toutes les nuances de
gauche union européenne se penche
aujourd'hui sur l'examen d'une série d'
une sixième série de sanctions surtout
l'union européenne va instaurer un
embargo sur le pétrole russe l'article
soyons clair ce ne sera pas facile car
certains états membres sont très
dépendants du pétrole russe mais nous
devons le faire deux pays pourront être
exemptés la hongrie et la slovaquie qui
dépendent totalement du pétrole russe
ils auront jusqu'à 2023 pour mettre en
place d'autres alternatives vous nous
avez tissé oui c'est possible c'est pas
vous tout simplement c'est un outil de
montage pour montrer que la russie n'a
suffisamment les moyens pour répondre à
toute menace à tout genre de menace la
france me lasse
pas du tout edouard philippe lui veut
présenter beaucoup de candidats aux
législatives pour peser et sa emmanuel
macron s'est lui fait très peur entre
les deux hommes donc ça chauffe un
certain nombre d'élus qui aujourd'hui
pour acheter des voix ont fait le choix
de faire des pactes avec l'islam
politique
et moi en tant que président de région
j'ai toujours été très clair je ne
l'accepterai pas et on ne sera pas
complice de sang on découvre tout le
bien qu emmanuel macron pense de son
ancien premier ministre aucune
circonscription pour horizon ce sont des
cons il ne doit tout ils pensent qu'on
est égaux il a fumé les vapeurs du port
du havre si la mairie de grenoble
devaient s'engager dans cette voie nous
nous cesserions tous travaillent avec le
maire de grenoble puis laurent wauquiez
souhaite poursuivre sa quête contre les
croyants musulmans il pourrait plutôt
que de s'occuper des piscines de
grenoble interdire le voile dans les
trains express régionaux ça relève de sa
compétence et là il peut laisser libre
cours avec nepal aventis
c'est qu'à mieux pensé voilà